et il se trouve que le ministre de la
francophonie c'est quelqu'un qui les
téléspectateurs connaissent très bien
puisque c'est alain decaux alain decaux
merci d'être avec nous ce soir vous êtes
à nice vous ne trouvez pas triste au
fond qu'on ne parle de francophonie
qu'au moment de la mort d'un poète
canadien
d'abord je crois qu'on en parle en bien
d'autres occasions mais voyez vous allez
c'est triste pour tous ceux qui ont aimé
félix leclerc
mais félix leclerc c'est le symbole même
de la francophonie parce que ce
québécois a fait connaître la réalité
québécoise aux français et en même temps
les français ont fait sa gloire
c'est ça la francophonie c'est un
échange vous êtes le ministre d'une idée
alain decaux c'est la francophonie donc
comment est-ce qu'on gère une idée est
ce que vous avez des projets très
concrets là nous donc pour vous pourriez
nous parler mais j'en ai j'en ai
tellement que les très courtes vacances
que m'accorde la république sont passées
à étudier les dossiers je pars je vais
partir dans quelques jours justement
pour le québec parce que on va lancer le
satellite canadien francophone tv5 la
langue française ils n'ont dans
l'amérique du nord est ce qu'on aurait
pu rêver ça il y a cinq ans ça c'est la
francophonie ensuite il y aura le gabon
parce que les africains s'inquiètent de
l'europe j'irai les rassurer l'europe et
à la francophonie ne croiront pas
mauvais ménage en suis sûr il y aura la
préparation de dakar le sommes mais
dakar il y aura aussi les jeux
francophones ou au maroc le sommet
franco africain tout cela c'est mon
calendrier médias alors beaucoup de
projets effectivement est ce que le fait
d'être un homme de médias ça vous sert
beaucoup un symbole de la société
médiatique au fond je voudrais que ça me
sert je voudrais que ça me serve parce
que on me connaît ce qui me regarde mon
bus dans tout cas depuis longtemps et je
voudrais profiter de cette presque
intimité pour expliquer aux français ce
qu'est la francophonie on ne sait pas
assez on ne sait pas assez que cette
communauté solidaire c'est le nom
qu'elle s'est donnée et bien non
seulement et des projets mais réalise
ses projets depuis depuis le sommet de
paris c'est un grand enjeu pour la
france et pour tous les pays qui se
rassemble mais je crois que ce sera l'un
des grands enjeux de la fin du xxème
siècle et j'essaierai de leur dire
pourquoi vous français alain decaux
dernière question est là je vais
m'adresser à l'académicien un autre
poète est mort en même temps hier c'est
francis ponge
ça ne vous attriste pas au fond qu'on ne
parle des poètes qu'à leur mort
j'ai beaucoup aimé pons a été peut-être
la plus grande émotion de mes 20 ans
congelés alors non ça ne m'attriste pas
parce que un poète ne meurt pas oui il
est parti mais demain je crois que je
relis réponds-je merci monsieur le
ministre
dans l'actualité encore la mort